I have found what I believe to be parasites possibly tapeworms, but not certain of the time there are so many right parasite programs. What would you recommend and how often?
Well, like doing any other programming other than what I program for you.
Well, as I've always said, you just have to play with it, you know, doing a parasite program once or twice isn't going to do anything, you know, any lasting good. You have to do it multiple times to see if it's even going to work for you.
I use the parasite all frequencies six hours low, which is a good one to use a couple times with the ground involved frost by lower belly.
You need to read of them as quickly as possible. The injured is insane and robbing me of sleep and might be contributing by ability to gain weight.
I've seen that food grade diatomaceous earth, one to two tablespoons in water, garlic, piacets, pumpkin seeds can be helpful for a couple of weeks.
Are these fast and effective a loader together? What would you recommend? We have a pair of clear product that we use.
It's our private label of PHP's vermouth huge, which I think is the best parasite cleanser because it's just, it's got so many good parasite killers in there, so it'll kill the widest array of parasites.
Going through a bottle that should be enough to kill most parasites in a person's body, typically you could kill parasites fairly quick.
Doing the parasite all frequencies is my favorite one than what I would recommend to do.